[Music]
decorum as a concept means not offending
good taste and all that and I decorum in
writing is a completely different
concept and it all it means is that the
content should suit the star should suit
the content there's nothing to do with
good taste no writer worth anything is
bothered by good taste which what is
good taste it's a shallow consensus of a
certain kind of right thinking
individual or group of individuals it's
measuring what you're saying to how
you're saying it then tremendously
foundational principle for writing and
and the experimental writer will of
course instinctively transgress against
these rules but you've got to realize
that your that all your guide ropes are
being jettisoned and the good will of
the reader is not infinite it's it's
usually very high as you open a novel
but if you mess around with the reader
at your whim that good will is very
quickly used up you know scream of
consciousness even Joyce has a very low
success rate with it you have to be a
genius to write the stream of
consciousness and even the supreme
genius
Joyce wrote his long normally spent 15
years on Finnegan's Wake is is flat-out
unreadable and even neuroses own only
about 25% of Ulysses works and I I've
come more and more to the conclusion
that if it's social realism your writing
then it a Bayes it's a so means the
novel is a sociable form it's a social
form and the writer is like a host and
the reader is like a guest and if you
when you visit an a back off novel it's
as if he has given you his the best
chair nearest the fire and given you his
best wine and giving you his full
attention in the most you know tactful
and sensitive way if you went round to
Joyce's house you'd find the address
didn't exist then you would find some
sort of outbuilding where Joyce lives
and then he wouldn't be in it apparently
and then you'd shout for him and
eventually a figure would appear and he
would talk to you in a language you've
never heard of before and instead of
giving you a delicious dinner as naba
coughed as Joyce would give you two
slabs of peat around a conga real it
would be and some repulsive drink he'd
made himself it's it's to leave social
realism and I've done it most writers do
it a couple of times in their career is
to is a great statement of of arrogance
and introversion and the huge risks
involved in leaving the path of social
realism and writers will be tempted to
do it every now and then and and
sometimes you can bring it off but but
you say goodbye to all those all the
etiquette of social intercourse which
governs the novel as it governs all our
dealings
[Music]